the
relatively prudent libs understand that
they have lost on this issue even even
joe biden this was
this i'll give him credit even though i
don't think he deserves total credit i
will give him credit when the dobbs
decision came down joe biden did not
call for violence and take to the
streets and get up in their faces and go
where their children sleep
joe biden said you got to remain
peaceful
i call on everyone no matter how deeply
they care about this decision
to keep all protest peaceful
peaceful peaceful peaceful no
intimidation
violence is never acceptable
threats
and tim and intimidation are not speech
we must stand against violence in any
form
regardless of your rationale
i'm glad he said this i'll give him
credit for saying this i hope it's
sincere i don't know that it's sincere
but
i always give him credit for saying it
i don't think the reason he said it is
because it's sincere i don't think joe
biden really has a ton of sincere
beliefs and he has used rhetoric that is
extraordinarily irresponsible throughout
his entire political career
don't forget when he was running for a
vice president he said that mitt romney
wants to put black people back in chains
okay this is a guy who is
called the president of the united
states a racist on tv he smeared some
kid as a white supremacist with
absolutely no evidence and then the kid
was exonerated in court
this is a guy who is willing to be fast
and loose with his language so i
this is a guy whose staff members
fundraised for the blm rioters during
the the summer of love with the mostly
peaceful arson and murder okay this is a
guy who chose as a vice president a
woman who herself raised money for the
rioters so i i just don't think it's
sincere some people say well look joe
biden down at the bottom of his heart
he's actually a good guy i don't think
he's a good guy i think he's a nasty
nasty man and a political opportunist
and i actually think opportunism
explains why he made this statement
i think this is the best he can do right
now
i think this is the absolute best joe
biden can do i think this plays very
well for him i think he knows that
coming out and being old nice uncle joe
and come on let's be peaceful folks
that's that's part of why he became
president why part of why he got the
nomination is to be a nice normal guy
that screeching and screaming and saying
burn it down doesn't play very well in
peoria particularly at this political
moment in this midterm election year so
i think he's doing it out of convenience
and opportunism
because the left has overplayed its hand
before we go
there's a story that just broke from
chris ruffo who's done a great job
covering critical race theory and some
of the
ways that the libs are trying to groom
our children there's a show coming out
from disney called baymax apparently i'm
not totally familiar with it and in the
new baymax show
which is accessible to really really
little kids what four years old maybe
even younger in the show the the robot
character is going shopping for tampons
and asks the women around him what
tampons he should use and he gets an
answer from someone who looks like a man
but is obviously not a man because he
uses tampons he's a he's a transgender
he's a woman pretending to be a man
[Music]
excuse me which of these products would
you recommend
oh um
well
these are the tampons i usually use
thank you i prefer pads they're more
comfortable for me thank you i always
get the ones with wings thank you get
unscented and bleach free if you can
thank you yo my daughter loves these i
think these might be easier if it's our
first period these are really
environmentally friendly
and the way you know not to put too fine
a point on it but the way you know that
disney is really hitting it on the nose
here is the dude with the tampons is
wearing a transgender flag shirt this is
this is artwork that is being
intentionally peddled to really really
little kids where disney executives have
appeared on camera themselves and said
they are peddling the not so secret gay
agenda right there they're actively
pushing this stuff on kids
it's disordered it's bizarre it's wrong
it's also
is this good art to you do you think
this is good do you think good art is
really pedantic and didactic and talks
about menstruation for little tiny
children and has weird creepy uh like
marshmallowy freaky nightmare cartoon
robots next to transgender dude chicks i
don't know i don't think that's good art
would you rather have your kid watch
this or beauty and the beast
this or snow white and the seven dwarves
i'm not saying that art shouldn't take
up challenging topics of course it
should one of my favorite painters in
history is caravaggio the guy is pretty
hardcore okay he presents very
difficult topics but in a way that is
beautiful ordered toward the good that
is edifying not that is creepy and
contrary to reality and pretends that
men are secretly actually women and
tries to groom the little kids
this the art really matters here folks
we can we we definitely want to own the
lives of facts and logic we can totally
do that we definitely need to focus on
arguing from a real moral order that we
can know something about the difference
between good and evil if we don't know
that we can't have self-government but
it's also important to focus on beauty
that third transcendental there it's a
good guidepost and if we want people to
be conservative if we want people to
love their country we need to give them
a country that is lovable that is
beautiful a place where they want to be
if you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show and i
i know that you did i trust that you did
check out the rest on apple podcast
spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts and most importantly of all
here's what we need we need you to
become a member at the daily wire okay
dailywire.com
knowles you'll get access to a library
of exclusive content you can use code
knowles save 25 on your new membership
today you will help us fight this fight
we have racked up some pretty big wins
here at dw specifically and on the
conservative side
we can only do it when you put your
money where our mouths are so we really
appreciate your support right now
dailywire.com knowles save 25 percent
[Music]
[Music]
you